I AM BACK FROM THE CANADA BITCH !
Comment allez-vous ? Moi je suis de retour du Canada c'étais très bien j'ai passé de merveilleux moments.
J'espère que c'est le cas pour vous aussi, mais aujourd'hui on reprend le travail !
Le meilleur travail du monde si je puis dire !
Je suis très content, ça fais 2 mois que j'attends quelque chose ..!
J'attend depuis 2 mois LES RESULTATS D'UN TEST A.D.N !
POURQUOI, Squeezie fait-il un test ADN ?
Ecoutez, c'est une histoire très très simple issue d'un traumatisme créé quand j'étais au collège
Au collège c'était tout simplement, hyper classe, de dire :
"Ouais, j'ai un peu de racines espagnoles, ouais ^^"
"Ouais, mon grand-père il vivait au Portugal dans sa jeunesse, j'suis un peu portugais ^^"
Moi, face à ces gens, je ne pouvais que répondre :
"Moi, jsuis 100 % Babtou, J'ADORE!
"-AH starfullah, il a pas d'origines et tout !"
"*Bégaye* Et ta- et ta- eh ta gueule ! J'suis- j'suis un thug !
Et AUJOURD'HUI, après 21 ans d'ignorance sur mes origines, je vais ENFIN savoir d'où je viens !
BREF, il y a 2 mois j'ai commandé un kit A.D.N, ok ? J'ai dû mettre un coton-tige dans ma bouche pour récolter de la salive et l'envoyer à un laboratoire
Ils l'ont reçu le 14 juin, nous sommes, le 10 août au moment où je tourne cette vidéo
L'attente fût longue, mais les résultats sont là !
Ok, je viens de mettre tous mes identifiants, c'est partie !
Bienvenu Lucas Hauchard ! Bienvenu dans le monde de la généalogie A.D.N
Sur cette page, vous pouvez voir les résultats de votre généalogie... *Voix extrêmement viril* Oh je suis tout excité !! *Rires*
Et les aides à l'interprétation par iGENA.
"Résultats lignée paternelle" et "Résultats lignée maternelle" *tout excité* oh c'est FOU !
OH !
J'ai les résultats ce ça et de ça, mais j'ai pas les résultats du "M253 SNP Pack" Je sais pas ce que c'est du tout *bégaye* Je- J'en sais rien !
Attendus pour le ... *Voix de constipé louche ^^* 4 octobre ?!? *Cris de frustration* AAAAH !
Oh, du coup je peux pas voir les résultats de ma lignée paternelle
Parce que j'ai pris le méga test, et ils testent aussi ta... Ils arrivent à voir, les deux lignées : et paternelle et maternelle
Bon, c'est pas grave, au moins on a le maternelle
Alors, je viens d'où ? "Peuple d'origine : CELTE !"
~OMG je suis choqué, toi même tu sais~ Mec c'est fou !
OH il y a une carte et TOUT ! : "71 % Europe Occidentale et Centrale"
17 % Péninsule Ibérique..."
*Retour de la voix de constipé* MAIS NON ! *Rires*
JE POURRAIS INVITER MES POTES A MANGER DE LA MORUE !!!
OH mec ... *Rires*
Faut que j'appelle ma grand-mère , elle arrête pas de me dire :
"Voix bizarre de grand-mère* Lucas, nous sommes 100 % Français, je ne sais pas d'où nous venons...
Mes arrières-grands-parents à moi déjà étaient français, je ne sais pas d'où l'on vient ..."
Je pourrais lui dire : "Mamie, *tout fier* ON A UN PEU DE SANG ESPAGNOL !
Si on retourne au collège, on pourra se la péter Mamie !"
Oh putain...
"... 12 % Europe du Sud-Est." ... *surpris* OOOOOH...
Ouais, donc j'suis quand même à 70 % euh... d'ici
Et par contre, 17 % Péninsule Ibérique mec ! Ça ... Alors ça c'est surprenant ! C'est FOU !
*Voix de regrets* Ah, j'suis dégoûté de pas avoir le carte paternelle et maternelle, voir mes origines précisément !
J'AURAIS APPELÉ MA GRAND-MÈRE ! J'AURAIS PU LUI DIRE !
Parce que là, je sais pas si c'est plutôt la lignée de mon père qui vient de la Péninsule Ibérique ou si c'est plutôt la lignée de ma mère !
Et pareil pour l'Europe du Sud-Est !
Mais je pense que ma mère *Bégaille* ... j'pense que ma mère c'est Europe du Sud-Est.
*Essaie d'expliquer une illumination* Elle ... Euh ... Elle est très bronzée, ma mère ...
*Se rend compte que ce qu'il a dit ne tient pas debout* *rire embarrassé*
ÇA N'A AUCUN SENS !
Ok, il est maintenant temps de passer à : L'ORIGINE PRÉHISTORIQUE !
"Le continent Européen a connu de nombreux épisodes de migrations humaines, dont certaines se sont étalées sur des milliers d'années
La recherche la plus récente sur ces migrations anciennes suggère que trois groupes majeurs d'humains ont eu un effet durable sur les populations actuelles d'origines européennes.
"Des chasseurs cueilleurs, des agriculteurs précoces et des envahisseurs de l'age de bronze."
OK
*SqueeziePerduQuiBégaye* Alors ... Je ... J'suis ... Je ... J'étais quoi ???
"47 % Agriculteurs"
"42 % de Chasseurs-Cueilleurs"
"Et 11 % d'Indo-européen"
*Inspire entre ses dents* Je ne comprends ... Pas ces valeurs
Je sais pas comment le prendre, je sais pas si je dois être content ou pas ... *Rires*
Ou alors n'en avoir rien à foutre... Je sais pas !  ... Je ... Je sais pas ce ... *pet de bouche*
Donc mec ... Je suis 100 % européen !
MAIS, j'ai 17 % de sang Espagne-Portugal mon gars, c'est FOU !
Je vais quand même appeler ma grand-mère, je vais lui dire :
"Mamie, j'ai fais un test A.D.N. ...
... On descend des Celtes !
VOILÀ. Elle fera ce qu'elle veut avec cette information. Moi je trouve ça très amusant !
*Le téléphone sonne 1 fois ...*
Mauricette : Allô ?
Lucas : Comment vas-tu Mamie ?
Mauricette : Aaahhh, c'est toi, Lucas ?
Lucas : Ouais, ça va ?
Mauricette : Bonjour ! T'es rentré ?
Lucas : Ouais, j'suis rentré ! Là, j'suis, en fait, j'suis en train de faire une vidéo
Et je t'appelais parce que ... Tu sais, j'ai fais un test A.D.N ?
*Gros blanc bien gênant*
Mauricette : OUI !
Lucas : Et bah écoute, j'ai pas encore les résultats exactes, Mais je sais, que nous descendons ... Des Celtes
Mauricette : *Choquée* AH BON ?!
Lucas : Voilà ! On descend des Celtes du côté maternelles, donc de ton côté ... On descend des Celtes !
Mauricette : Aaaaah bon !
Alors c'est bon ça !
*Lucas éclate de rire*
Lucas : Toi aussi tu sais pas quoi faire de cette information ?
Mauricette : *Rires*
Par contre, j'ai les résultats de mon sang à moi
Ça comprend ET les origines maternelles ET paternelles
Donc je suis à 70 % issu d'Europe occidentale et centrale
Sans surprise !
Mauricette : Oui ... ?
17 % de la Péninsule Ibérique ! Donc Espagne-Portugal ...
Et 12 % de L'Europe du Sud-Est, donc Grèce, Italie ...
Mauricette : Alors, c'est plutôt tout ça méditerranéen là hein !
Lucas : Ouais ! Mais du coup, à ton avis, est-ce que c'est VOUS, qui venez de la Péninsule Ibérique, ou est-ce que c'est Papa ?
C'est ça là question ! *Rires*
Mauricette : *Rires*
Lucas : Moi jpense que côté maternelle c'est Péninsule Ibérique parce que Maman elle est bronzée ... Naturellement. *Rires gênés*
Mauricette : Effectivement ! Hein ! D'ailleurs, beaucoup de personnes pensaient qu'elle était espagnole, tu sais quand elle était jeune ...
Lucas : *l'interrompt* ET BAH VOILÀ ! TOUT S'EXPLIQUE !!!
DONC, ça vient de Maman à mon avis ...
Mauricette : *coupe Lucas* Ma MÈRE, justement, la grand-mère de ta mère ...
Lucas : Ouais, ouais
Mauricette : ... elle était franchement avec un type espagnol ...
Lucas : *coupe Mauricette* Bah alors, voilà ! Mais c'est sûr, ça vient de vous !
Et Papa il est blanc comme un CUL !!!!
Il vient de la Serbie, c'est évident !
Mauricette : Aaah bah OUI, oui, effectivement !
Lucas : *Rires*
Et bah écoute, le mystère est résolu Mamie ! : Tu es espagnole.
Mauricette : Et bah, t'as bien travaillé, tu vois
Lucas : Bah ouais *tout fier de lui*
J'ai surtout payé très cher, mais ... Euh ... Ouais.
En tous cas, moi, je suis à 17 % espagnol Mamie ! Tu m'aimes toujours ?
Mauricette : Bah bien sûr j't'aime toujours, pourquoi ?
Lucas : *Rires*
Lucas : Nan, c'était une blague mais ... c'est- c'est ... t'as pas compris, mais c'est pas grave !
Bah écoute ma Mamie, on se voit bientôt pour l'anniversaire de Florent ?
Mauricette : (Babillage incompréhensible)
Lucas : Ouais, ça marche !
Ouais ... (clairement ennuyé ...)
~#SOS, #MaMamieMeSpam, #LacheMoiStp~
Lucas : Et bah moi de même...
Bisous Mamie ! Je t'aime !
*Soupir* Putain, je l'ai appelée HIER !
COMMENT, en seulement 24 heures elle a retrouvé autant de choses à me dire ?? *Rires*
Bah les amis, je crois que voilà hein la vérité vraie elle est là on a vu hein, grâce à cette carte. J'suis, terriblement déçu de pas pouvoir voir en détail d'où vient mon père et d'où vient ma mère
Ecoutez, on le saura apparemment en OCTOBRE !
Je referai un vidéo quand il y aura la carte du monde disponible pour la lignée maternelle et la lignée paternelle
Ça sera amusant !
MAIS MEC J'SUIS ESPAGNOL !!
*Se met à parler Espagnol, avec un accent pourri* "Salut, je suis espagnol ! Je veux aller au Jetski"
*Rires gênés*
C'est horrible
J'fais vraiment des imitations, on est pas loin du racisme quoi, c'est fou ...
*BIIIIIIP*
Et bah les amis, c'est la FIN de cette vidéo, j'espère que ça vous a plus ! Putain, j'suis trop content ! N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si c'est le cas
Et j'suis trop content putain, ça fait vraiment depuis- depuis 10 ans que je me dis :
"Mais c'est pas possible Maman, nos ancêtres il y a mille ans, ils viennent forcément d'ailleurs ..."
*Imite sa maman* : TU TE TAIS ET TU ÉCOUTES EN COURS D'SVT LUCAS !!
Et bah aujourd'hui BOUM j'ai la réponse !
Enfin bref la morale de l'histoire c'est que, on vient tous de loin en réalité
C'est totalement impossible que quelqu'un fasse ce test et qu'il soit à 100 % français ou alors c'est ULTRA rare !
Ça se trouve, vous détestez les Anglais, et vous avez du sang anglais *Clin d'oeil pour la punchline*
On finit sur un mot gentil : peu importe d'où vous venez ; moi JE M'EN BATS LES COUILLES !
Ce sont vos actions qui comptent. Pas vos origines.
La morale nulle de Lucas !
Allez les amis, je vous aimes, merci d'avoir regardé.
Ça m'a fait très plaisir de faire cette vidéo, j'attendais ça depuis longtemps et puis ... À bientôt !
Dites au revoir en Espagnol allez c'est partie en Espagnol :
Adiiosss !!